من رام الله جيفارا البداري معنا من هناك
مباشره جبال حديثين عما يمكن ان نتوقعه
اليوم
نعم الصوره تتحدث عن نفسها ليلى في هذه
الاثناء يصل الالاف من الفلسطينيين الذين
انتقلوا وانطلقوا في مسيره حاشده من امام
ضريح الرئيس الشهيد ياسر عرفات الى هنا
صوبه وسط المدينه دوار المناره يرفعون
علما فلسطينيا كبيرا جدا ومن يحملهم طلبت
المدارس ايضا الطلبه يرفعون الاعلام
الفلسطينيه اسماء
531 قريه وبلده دمرتها العصابات الصهيونيه
عام
1948 بالطبع كان يتقدم هذه المسيره كافه
القيادات السياسيه من كل الاطياف السياسيه
وايضا الفعاليات الوطنيه
ورجال الدين
ويعني مم عن المؤسسات المجتمع المدني في
هذه الاثناء ايضا نرى رئيس الوزراء
الفلسطيني يصل ايضا الى هنا الى دوار
المناره بعد ان القى كلمه امام ضريحه
الرئيس الشهيد ياسر عرفات اكد فيها ان
الاهميه لهذا اليوم
الجلسه التي ستعقدها الامم المتحده لاول
مره لاحياء ذكرى النكبه وكانه اعتراف بما
ارتكب بحق الشعب الفلسطيني واكد ان الرئيس
الفلسطيني هذا هذا المساء وفي تمام
السابعه بتوقيت مكه المكرمه سيلقي خطابا
باسم 14 مليون فلسطيني يسرد روايه اصحاب
الارض الاصليين ضحايا نكبه عام 48 ويفند
الروايه الاسرائيليه المزيفه والكاذبه
واكد ان النكبه الجريمه ممتده على مدار 75
عاما ولا يزال الشعب الفلسطيني يدفع من
دمه لحمه الحي فاتوره هذا العدوان وذلك
رغم استمرار النضال الفلسطيني لاسترداد
الحقوق وافشال المشروع الصهيوني
الاستعماري التوسعي اذا هذه الكلمه
الرسميه التي القاها رئيس الحكومه
الفلسطينيه امام ضريحه الرئيس عرفات كما
نرى عبر عدسه الكاميرا الليله الفلسطينيون
هنا من كل الاطياف السياسيه الشعبيه من
طلبه المدارس حيث تم تعليق الدوام في
المدارس والجامعات والمؤسسات الرسميه
والحكوميه في تمام الثانيه عشره ظهرا
للمشاركه في احياء الذكرى الخامسه
والسبعين للنكبه الفلسطينيه يحملون كما
ذكرنا اسماء كل القرى والبلدات التي تم
هدمها وتدميرها عام النكبه شيء اخير بعد
اقل من نصف ساعه في تمام الواحده ظهرا تدق
صافرات الحداد ل 75 ثانيه في اشاره ل75
سنه من النكبه الفلسطينيه التي يؤكد
الفلسطينيون انها لازالت متواصله